hi everybody
program office at the Smithsonian it's
under the office of the chief
information officer there and we work
with all the museums archives libraries
galleries to increase the quality and
quantity of digitization across the
organization specifically my role is to
increase the impact of said digitization
so how do we get the maximum mileage out
of all the work that we're putting into
what we're doing and computer vision and
machine learning and things like this
are one of the most exciting ways that I
think that we can show the potential of
our collections at scale and so this is
definitely something that merits a lot
of attention and focus this is sort of
two parts first I've been haunting a lot
of sort of trade show industry
conferences over the past few months to
sort of see what other industries are
doing with the technology how they're
thinking about it how far along you know
one group is versus another
so in NVIDIA conference late last year
you know they've convinced me that GPUs
will solve all of our problems but
beyond the propaganda it's clear that
this is having an effect across all
industries this is not something that's
sort of unique and we definitely need to
make sense of it sooner or later and
Sooners ideal in my mind I went to a
conference run by a am called museums
and new intelligence new intelligences
the emphasis there was really on in
gallery experiences so imagine a camera
may be tracking visitors expressions and
they may be happy or sad or bored or
excited and that's kind of a way to get
a metric I think that's super
interesting I also think that's
something that is going to be
commoditized by a lot of other
industries and and that's probably not
the domain that we need to worry too
much about making progress
GSA future services now was a government
centric conference the clear message
there was that across agencies they're
thinking about this technology and
they're aggregating there as well and so
their one major set of stakeholders that
the Smithsonian and I think cultural
heritage can look to to leverage our
data against government data National
Academy of Sciences the science of deep
learning a lot of the scientists went a
bit out of their way to say
this is not a black box it's a very big
complicated box and you don't know how
it works until you've built it and
you've run it and see how it breaks but
there is recourse when things go wrong
and you can go back and see how do you
need to two-week things and I think the
real trick with this stuff is the lack
of transparency that most industries
have in making models available and for
us I think one of our superpowers that
we've been leveraged here is our ability
to be more transparent with these models
and we could play a major role with with
ethics and standard operating procedures
for how we use this technology
fantastic futures which was a conference
put on with Stanford University
Libraries and national library of Norway
and their librarians are great they can
adapt to anything and say yeah that
stuff librarians do and they were pretty
ready to say yeah it really doesn't make
sense to strictly think in terms of the
libraries you know this is a scenario
where we're all stronger together across
disciplines
another really critical thing there was
I heard a bit about triangulating low
quality low accuracy data to get high
quality results and if you think about
our collections records when we get our
collections records perfect we put them
out into the world and we're very proud
of it when our collections records are
not perfect we hide them and shame until
we either you know retire or until we
have time to get around to making it
perfect then we'll release it and I
think that making finding a way to make
this imperfect data visible and
something that we can compute against to
bootstrap the quality of our data is a
critical possibility there's a kind of a
standard explainer for machine learning
versus classical programming so this was
useful for me to sort of wrap my head
around a really fundamental difference
between what we're doing here and I
think this is sort of the cultural
change that a lot of folks across the
Smithsonian are going to need to wrap
their heads around as well
you sort of switch the equation a little
bit I think the really interesting thing
is the possibility of bootstrapping and
the fact that we do have all the raw
ingredients with our data as it stands
flaws and all to get much better data
out of what we currently have it our
disposal moving on to a workshop and
presentation series that we did in a
collaboration with Google arts and
culture and the data science lab with
Rebecca deco basically the goal here was
to introduce people from across the
Smithsonian to general premises of
machine learning through a webcast and
lecture series and then we also did a
workshop where we invited a bunch of
people from different disciplines from
across the Smithsonian to sort of think
about how this applies to their own work
you can see the very credible gentleman
on the left hand side there with his
hand gestures so very simply the goals
here were to provide a basic
introduction to machine learning try to
identify what our common challenges are
and then also to be very deliberate
about developing grounds for
collaboration very much like what we're
doing here today and I think what keeps
me excited about this stuff is just this
visualization and defining what this
long tail of our cultural heritage
collections are if we can do that and
the more specifically we can do that I
think the more important we become not
just at getting good at using these
tools but at giving back to the industry
and playing a role and how AI and
machine learning and machine the
provision in every variation of these
terms is affecting our world tried to
visualize as a handful of different ways
because nobody ever seems to think
that's as important as I do this this is
something I pulled together on the train
it's kind of lame I think this is more
compelling but not as accurate so how
did we go about organizing this event we
had approximately 50 different
participants so on the left hand side
here you can see representation from
different units sometimes we had a
couple of people from a unit sometimes
just one rep and basically we organized
them in two different cohorts with
different themes accessibility American
women's history initiative art history
culture informatics and metadata science
search and discovery transcription and
translation and as you can see by this
next slide open up wait for that punch
line we came up with about 65
independence concepts that were drives
and some of these were sort of one-off
somebody said hey this would be a great
idea write it down that's a concept
other things that were brought to the
table were things that folks have been
thinking about for months or years and
want to bring to the table too as a
possible project to move forward and now
you can see as we break down all these
individual concepts and try to find what
the relationship is between them we now
have a tangled mess when we we tried to
matically organize what our interests
were it no longer made sense and so the
physical boundaries of you know the
walls of our museums as we make the
digital transition or making less and
less sense but I think that with this
wave of new technology they are going to
make less sense far more quickly and
it's something that we can prepare for
some of the critical strategic interests
were bias of course and understanding
the bias in our own collections this is
something I feel strongly is a risk of
course but I think it's a potential
benefit as much it is as it is a
liability so I'll try to talk a little
bit more about that
data and training collections
enhancement so that would be the idea of
you know bootstrapping our metadata up
into something higher quality higher
accuracy audience driven priorities
things like enhanced search like we've
seen examples of today as well we also
can organize these ideas into sort of
more tech centric themes and again it's
a tangled mess of knots where our
traditional disciplines no longer make
as much sense
and it also means a tremendous
opportunity for us to be more efficient
about how we develop so I'm going to
zoom in here to specifically the
American Women's History Initiative
concepts that were developed and what
we're looking at here on the left hand
side is the group of about four people
who are working on the American Women's
History cohort and if you track the
purple lines on top over the right hand
side those were the ideas that they came
up with don't worry about reading the
fine print too much down here we have
other cohorts that came up with ideas
that were strongly related to or
applicable to American women's history
and so you can see those popping up on
the right hand side and then basically
what you have here is a list of ideas
that do the most good for the most
people based on the interests expressed
at this workshop as opposed to what
might be the project's represented on
top which maybe have all the virtue in
the world in and of itself but does not
offer as much opportunity for us to
build upon we're gonna track backwards
now and and see how well this method
might be useful at this layer we can see
all the key internal stakeholders so
what unit units across the Smithsonian
are interested in these particular
concepts what was that individual origin
concept that got truncated into these
more overarching themes and essentially
we have all the details that are so
difficult in getting traction on a given
project so this isn't an argument to
think beyond our grasp
but it is an argument to initiate and
design projects with lots of open doors
for expansion and new opportunities when
we come to the conclusion in these
collaborations and I think that's what
this type of mindset might help with and
I think the point here is that we can
overlay any type of content with this
concept so these were a number of
different proposals that stemmed some
from the workshop and some were ideas
that were in progress originally and
we're proposed to as collaborations with
Google but the exciting thing is that we
could take any other idea and basically
do an analysis of how many how effective
it would be for our overarching goals
and we can be pretty flexible in terms
of which content we choose to run with
in this respect and in terms of bias and
I think the the shackles example which
is really important on one hand it's a
huge liability when we mislabel an
object like that and it can be hugely
damaging I don't want to underestimate
the severity of that as an issue but I
also think that there is a flip side and
an opportunity there and in the end what
happened is that surfaced a deficiency
in the model that's being used and I
think that's a really critical role that
we can play and cultural heritage in
general with our data on the periphery
of what general tech companies have
access to we're really going to be the
critical last mile in making a lot of
what they want to do possible so it's
basically I think we should I'm
advocating for us to value what we have
to offer the rest of industry as much as
we're excited about how we can use this
tech in in-house
[Applause]
[Music]